[музика]
дорогі працівники в закладі дошкільної
освіти Вітаємо вас з Днем дошкілля
давайте розпочнемо наш захід з хвилини
мовчання вшановуючи пам'ять всіх
українців які загинули внаслідок війни
[музика]
дорогі вихователі і виховательки вітаю
Вас із Днем дошкілля щиро захоплююся і
пишаюся вашою працею для дітей ви не
лише вихователі ви наставники які
закладають основу розуміння цього світу
дитячий садок - це перше місце куди
батьки проводять малечу щоб та навчилися
самостійності і відповідальності це не
завжди вдається одразу діти можуть
плакати вередувати але ви залишаєтесь
поруч і завжди знаєте як підтримати
дошкілля це не лише про догляд за
дитиною дошкілля - це про розвиток тож
ваш внесок у майбутнє України
надважливий адже саме ви закладаєте
фундамент фундамент цінностей у наших
дітях ви вчите їх бути собою пояснюйте
чому не можна ображати інших та як
вибачитися Якщо зробив помилку вивчите
маленьких українців допитливості
допомагаєте розвивати таланти та
проявляти творчість
а під час війни ваша роль стає ще більш
важливою ви навчаєте дітей адаптивності
гнучкості вчите дотримуватися правил
безпеки ви піклуєтеся про їхнє фізичне і
психологічне здоров'я
саме вам батьки довіряють найдорожче і Я
чудово розумію яка це величезна
відповідальність і ви чи
відповідальність берете на себе щодня
тож завдання нашої команди допомогти вам
створити нові можливості для розвитку
дошкілля та ліпші умови для роботи
найкращий старт зумовлює найкращий
результат саме тому ми повинні
інвестувати в дошкілля кошти зусилля та
час окремо хочу подякувати і привітати
тих вихователів які зробили винятковий
внесок освіту під час війни
Валентина Іванівна Моргулець
вихователька що продовжила роботу майже
одразу після деокупації Бучі до закладу
освіти діставалися самостійно
велосипедом через заміновані поля
Голубович Наталя Федорівна помічниця
вихователя яка з першого дня
повномасштабного вторгнення поєднувала
професійну і волонтерську діяльність
після роботи з дітьми вона плела
маскувальні сітки для фронту
команда
ясел-садку Джерельце який зараз
перебуває в аварійному стані через
авіакатастрофу колеги я знаю як ви
чекаєте на відновлення роботи бажаю вам
всім сил терпіння та наснаги для усіх
вас маємо особливу нагороду міць
української освіти Дякую за вашу роботу
і Я вдячний кожному і кожній хто працює
в дошкіллі попри все заради дітей зі
святом
[музика]
сьогодні для дитини це справжній друг
учитель наставник і людина до якої
дитини біжить в обійми і саме ці люди
закладають нашим дітям впевненість в
собі впевненість в тому що вони можуть
Знайти вихід із будь-яких ситуацій
Дорогі наші любі вихователі ви першими
навчаєте наших дітей що таке добро
що таке ви навчаєте їх дружити бути з
собою любити величезну роботу для того
щоб наша нація була не просто розумна а
ще й здорова Саме від вашого першого
доторку залежить те які ми будуть наші
дітки дай дитині вчителя із дитиною
виросте хороша людина здатна творити
щось прекрасне
зараз ставши багатодітною мамою і
повівши своїх малюків у дитсадочок я
розумію наскільки це титанічна і важлива
справа ми як батьки трьох дітей про це
не уявляємо що кожного дня переживаєте
Ви тому ми насправді вами захоплюємось
Бажаю всім вихователям отримувати
навзаєм таку ж любов яку ви віддаєте
своїм вихованцям бажаю терпіння здоров'я
щоб попри такий важкий складний час ми
все одно мали цю жагу ростити виховувати
найкрутіших українських дітей Дякую вам
дякую що ви є Дякуємо любимо
[музика]
Доброго дня дорогі колеги вітаємо вас
всіх з днем дошкілля а Сьогодні ми
зібралися тут аби поговорити про виклики
з сьогодення про можливості і привітати
вас також Сьогодні в нас буде такий
формат розмови і Починаємо ми з розмови
з заступницею міністра освіти і науки
України з дошкільної освіти та інклюзії
Євгенія смірнової Вітаю вас Доброго дня
Давайте я зразу розпочну з питань
чому день дошкілля
Чому він нам потрібен І взагалі яка роль
є у вихователі сьогодні
А ви знаєте напевно найкраще це розкаже
історію а історію незламності
вихователів котрі працюють під час
блекаутів повітряних тривог котрі на
руках спускають дітей в укриття він
заслуговує не просто поваги шани а
суспільного визнання
Дякую кожній і кожному за вашу щоденну
надважку працю
Дякую Євгенія і я хочу тут доповнити
насправді знаєте те як ми дорослі
реагуємо в часі кризи буде залежати те
як діти будуть транслювати і розуміти те
що відбувається навколо них і власне наш
героїзм наш дорослих хто опікується
дітьми якраз проявляється в оцих
щоденних вчинках просто питання Те що
наші щоденні вчинки сьогодні є часто
дуже складними і підкріплені воєнним
станом А що є дошкілля особисто для вас
для мене взагалі дошкілля - це про на
першому місці про дитину суспільство і
державу в цілому і про економічний вплив
тому що вихователі - це ті люди і
дошкільні заклади котрі беруть дітей і
дають можливість мамам і татам виходити
на роботу і залишати дитину в безпеці і
давати їй розпис а вихователі - це перші
провідники в життя дитини вони
життя вони можуть стати добрим другом
наставником і той внутрішньою опорою і
силою для дитини а також і для батьків
Євгенія ви долучилися до команди
Міністерства освіти і науки майже три
місяці тому Якщо я не помиляюся Скажіть
будь ласка які виклики стоять перед вами
і Які у вас плани і у вашої команди три
місяці в команді стали великим викликом
наш головний пріоритет - це зміна оплати
праці тому що ми не довіряємо
найцінніше це самих маленьких дітей і
люди хто їх забирають вони несуть
кримінальну відповідальність за їх життя
і здоров'я Ми також працюємо над
створенням дружніх укриттів до дитини ще
хочеться зазначити що ми хочемо
максимально зняти навантаження з
вихователів зробити все можливо для
дебюрократизації всіх процесів і щоб
вони були зайняті на роботі то з дітьми
а не заповненнями попертів котрі іноді
просто не потрібні Дякую Євгенієм Я хочу
поставити
останнє запитання яке можливо буде також
надихаючим для всіх наших педагогів Яка
місія є вашої команди а Головна наша
мета щоб дітям ми змогли забезпечити
безпечно та комфортне дитинство а для
педагогів створили гідні а та комфортні
умови праці Дякую дуже це насправді дуже
слушно і насправді це великий виклик
особливо в умовах війни але і для цього
ми всі зібралися тут аби говорити про
можливості аби говорити про важливість
вихователя Сьогодні я вас також вітаю з
днем дошкілля і ми передаємо наші
вітання усім хто сьогодні разом з нами
Дякуємо вам дякуємо вам
дорогі вихователі Ми раді вас вітати з
Днем дошкілля і також ми сьогодні будемо
мати таких декілька різних цікавих
розмов і Починаємо ми з розмови про свій
психологічний стан і про своє ментальне
здоров'я ви знаєте якщо ми
поставимо собі питання А які в мене є
спогади з дитячого садка то ми Якщо
говорити про добрі спогади ми найчастіше
згадаємо вихователя який нас підтримував
любив обіймав і був тим важливим
дорослим в нашому житті при якому
пам'ятаємо і досі і дуже важливо щоб той
дорослі в нашому житті Наші вихователі
дбавали про себе і відповідно могли бути
підтримкою дітям Отож наш перший блок це
буде блок про психологічну підтримку та
про ментальне здоров'я і сьогодні з нами
проводити майстер-клас або іншими
словами практикум буде відмінна Горбенко
психолог кандидатка педагогічних наук
співзасновниця здосад можливостей щастя
кіц і ми з пані Інною будемо
говорити про різні техніки вправи для
власного психологічного стану і для
взаємодії з дітьми пані Інно зразу таке
в мене перше питання Що в себе включає
безпека в контексті ментального здоров'я
бо про фізичну безпеку ми говоримо часто
так у нас обов'язково мають бути укриття
а от ментальне здоров'я це вже такі речі
знаєте які не можна виміряти фізично
конкретних категоріях що саме включає в
себе така безпека ну перш ніж говорити
про безпеку в контексті ментального
здоров'я давайте взагалі пригадаємо що
таке ментальне здоров'я і власне це стан
спокою рівноваги щастя при якому людина
може ефективно функціонувати
реалізовувати якісь свої задуми робити
свій внесок в розвиток суспільства і
звичайно ми вже дуже багато часу живемо
в війні ми зустрічаємося з різним
досвідом ми зустрічаємося з різними
часом непростими такими емоційними
переживаннями і безпека в контексті
ментального здоров'я це найперше про ось
цю здатність повертати собі стан спокою
рівноваги Коли я можу справді далі
працювати Це про те як я взагалі розумію
що зі мною зараз відбувається Чи можу я
надати Раду собі і якщо не можу то чи
знаю я до кого я можу звернутися за
допомогою і сьогодні ось те що ми дуже
часто чуємо потрібно дбати про себе це
не розкіш сьогодні це просто обов'язок
кожного із нас якщо ми хочемо А ми
безумовно всі хочемо не лише вистояти а
й перемогти в цій війні тому власне
безпека в контексті ментального здоров'я
це про ось цю роботу про себе Дякую дуже
знаєте
раніше коли ми мали можливість ні
чекайте це не треба говорити
Дуже дякую знаєте оце таке правило є
в літаках з першого дня маску на себе а
потім допоможи дитині там чи іншим і
мені здається що до повномасштабної
війни ми не зовсім саме це правило добре
розуміли А зараз власне для того аби ми
дорослі були підтримкою дітям підтримкою
іншим ми маємо дбати якраз про себе і
давайте ми поговоримо зараз про такі
техніки що важливо робити для того аби в
довгостроковій перспективі підтримувати
свої психічне здоров'я і які я наприклад
вправи для того аби допомогти собі от
тут і зараз в конкретний момент
справді сьогодні кожного дня дуже добре
якщо ми це будемо робити відводити
якийсь час от виключно для себе Коли я
можу щось зробити Чи я можу чимось
помилуватися для того щоб поповнити себе
да цими якимись позитивними емоціями
підтримувати ось цей власний ресурс
знаєте дуже часто це саме використовують
цю метафору і це справді так якщо ми
хочемо допомогти дитині то передусім ми
маємо допомогти собі мені ще дуже
подобається
метафора з ковдрою Да що зараз ми всі
просто виснажені вже і часом відчуваємо
такий стан коли хочеться сховатися під
ту ковдру щоб нічого не бачити
ізолюватися від якихось певних речей але
нам дорослими особливо тим які працюють
з маленькими дітьми Важливо пам'ятати що
ми якраз є тією кепкою ковдрою для
дитини так і від нашого спокою рівноваги
буде залежати Наскільки безпечно дитина
почуває себе з нами Ми можемо дати
дитині виключно те що маємо собі не
можна дати спокій дитині і стану там
збудження такого
якогось резбалансованості
роздратованості та і тому безумовно ті
техніки які сьогодні дуже багато
пропонують сьогодні дуже багато різних
можливостей для навчання безумовно
важливо їх виконувати а не тільки просто
про них знати так Так ми ж мабуть якщо
хочемо там підтримати своє тіло Да ми
йдемо в спортивний зал займаємося лежачи
на диван на дивані ми не будемо там да
е-е щось корисне для себе робити тому
дуже важливо ще і не тільки знати про цю
техніки а й безумовно виконувати їх
А що
можемо робити Я до речі хочу
запропонувати вам таку першу техніку і
це про таку постійну мабуть підтримку
про себе особливо вона називається пиріг
щастя і можемо якраз і всі Хто слухає
зараз нас теж можемо разом виконати цю
техніку Намалюйте будь ласка зараз на
аркуші паперу велике велике коло а а ви
Дорогі колеги хто нас слухає ви так само
можете долучатися до нас і разом з нами
в нас буде гарна синергія та загалом
працювати так і розділіть будь ласка
зараз це коло так як ми Уявіть собі
круглий такий пиріг або як підсум ми
ділимо на вісім таких частин і подумайте
так
і подумайте будь ласка зараз про те що
вам особисто додає сили енергії що вас
наповнює це можуть бути якісь дії
наприклад для когось це спорт для когось
це там
прогулянка природа його збирання грибів
тобто якась Дія це можуть бути якісь
безпечні місця інколи для того щоб
поповнити свій ресурс нам достатньо
прийти там я думаю кожного є якісь
улюблений куточок наприклад природи там
десь в місті чи там на околицях де ми
живемо таке місце може бути і нас в
будинку чи в квартирі це можуть бути
люди спілкування з якими також
і приносить нам ось це задоволення
і будь ласка в кожному із цих частиночок
в кожній частиночок Напишіть або
Намалюйте свій ресурс що вам додає сили
енергії що дає можливість
справлятися з усіма цими викликами які
сьогодні є
так тобто Дорогі колеги у вас має бути 8
таких
різних причин не причин як ми можемо це
назвати
ну власне це є ті джерела 8 різних
джерел які вас наповнюють Ну і добре
писати Там не просто одним словом
наприклад сім'я зрозуміло що сім'я для
нас є підтримкою але мабуть є те що ви
любите разом робити Можливо це ввечері
там перегляд фільму разом можливо це
прогулянка разом якщо для вас джерелом
енергії є квіти то що саме споглядання
квітів Чи ви отримаєте задоволення коли
ви їх там пересаджуєте щось з ними
робите це вже те що стосується виключно
якихось дій тобто треба дуже конкретно
формулювати те що ми робимо
Так я тут так швиденько знаєте можна
писати Можна зобразити це за допомогою
якихось символів
і ще один дуже важливий момент коли ми
думаємо ось про ці джерела Важливо щоб
вони були в доступі нашому да тому що
наприклад ну подорожуючи десь якимось
країнами Звичайно Це може нас
наповнювати але зараз можливо немає
можливостей для того щоб поїхати кудись
тому тут ще важливо зосередитися саме на
тих джерелах які нас наповнюють але вони
є доступними Зараз тут і зараз для нас
так я заповнила свої джерела які мене
наповнюють І знаєте що я хочу сказати
насправді
вони всі є дуже простими так от тобто
немає чарівної пігулки яку треба з'їсти
і тобі моментів з тим нелегко Бо
насправді про ті всі речі ми говоримо
завжди там сон корисна якісна їжа спорт
прогулянки тощо і ніби Здається це ж так
просто виконати для того аби Воно
насправді дієво так і дивіться Зараз ми
тільки думали прості джерела Ви думали
були виконували цю вправу А можете
поділитися от станом коли ви
розмірковували про те що для вас є
джерелом енергії
знаєте Я добре намагалася замислитися Чи
це справді є моє джерело енергії чи
наприклад це є джерело енергії яке
диктують зовні От
наприклад умовно я написала час з сім'єю
а потім я подумала про те що в будні дні
ми час з сім'єю є дуже таким поверхневим
бо ми всі в своїх знаєте е-е буднях дуже
є втомлені
зайняті я написала тоді детальніше
вихідні з сім'єю бо це якраз той час де
я можу бути в моменті і насправді майже
майже всі речі які я написала це про те
що ви будете в моменті Бо мені здається
знаєте такого масштабного війнами так
всі говорили що важливо бути моменті але
тільки зараз як на мене Ми зрозуміли як
це воно є насправді бути тут є зараз От
і це дуже важливо До речі структурувати
собі і десь написати бо одне знати про
це але навіть коли ми це вже написали
вголос наприклад про артикулювали ми вже
може сказати себе програмуємо на те аби
це виконувати або хоча би частково
виконувати Дякую що поділилися ну
зазвичай коли люди виконують цю вправу
діляться Що Ну от я тільки розмірковував
думав пригадував а вже відчуваю там
певний спокій чи радість і завдання не
лише в тому щоб там відслідкувати
прописати озвучити це а такий пиріг
щастя власне він може бути таким
нагадуванням шпаргалкою на кожен день
якою ми можемо користуватися по суті це
наші індивідуальні такі копінг стратегії
та у кожної людини вони є своїми і я
зазвичай рекомендую десь розмістити
навіть це кола в місцях де Ви часто
буває та можливо це на робочому місці
нагадування того що Кожного дня я маю
хоча би один шматочок з цього пирога
скуштувати щось зробити для себе Дуже
дякую
я насправді дуже знаєте надихнулася і
мені вже хочеться піти і виконати щось
для себе
так можемо рухатися далі так так Ну ще
хочу зауважити що дуже важливо зараз
відслідковувати
свої думки
і інколи самими думками ми можемо
заганяти себе в такий стан виснаження
повного Ну наприклад коли в нас постійно
як та заграна платівка крутиться Одна
думка про те що війна війна наскільки
Вона може продовжуватися Да я вже не маю
там сили і так далі тому є Чимало різних
технік які дають можливість саме
працювати з нашими думками Якщо ви
готові то я можу запропонувати вам одну
із таких технік і зараз знову-таки
Намалюйте будь ласка коло на аркуші
папери
коло є
і подумайте зараз будь ласка про те що
вас найбільше хвилює можливо це якісь
ситуації можливо це якісь думки і
всередині цього кола пропишіть будь
ласка от максимально все те що зараз
згадується
що тривожить що викликає стан Можливо
цієї тривоги такої
ви це пишете для себе це не потрібно
буде коментувати
і всіх хто зараз з нами з нами можуть
також виконати для себе цю вправу таку
підтримуючу
ті думки можливо якісь ситуації які
викликають зараз тривогу
не відпускай не заставляють весь час про
це думати Так я наче все я думаю Знаєте
тут Кожен з нас може поділити цьому
більше часу ніж от зараз кілька хвилин
так ми зараз хочемо техніку показати
використати її і зараз подумайте і за
колом можете скористатися попередньою
роботою
заколом можете символами позначити або
прописати все те що вас наповнює тобто
тут закон
та де Ми щойно писали за коло ми пишемо
всі ті техніки які писали да раз умовно
зараз так декілька напишу
декілька запишіть але виконуючи цю
вправу важливо ну достатньо дати часу
для того щоб прописати абсолютно все і
тут знову ж таки звертаємо увагу що це
ті джерела якісь зараз є доступними для
нас і чим більше до кола ми пропишемо
таких речей
тим краще
Так
я написала більшість і друга частина
цієї ж правої спробуйте зараз на іншому
аркуші паперу намалювати три кола так як
мішень так тобто маленьке коло більше і
ще більше От так правильно але так щоб
можна було в них писати Добре я зараз
намалюю і покажу
як ми можемо виглядати
правильно Ось так абсолютно Дякую ось
так
і зараз сфокусуйтеся будь ласка на тому
на тих думках ситуаціях які ви
прописували перед цим і в цьому
центральному колі пропишіть те що ви
можете контролювати можливо вам для
цього потрібні якісь додаткові ресурси
можливо вам для цього потрібно якась
підтримка допомога але точно є щось Що
ви можете зробити для того щоб там
наприклад розв'язати цю ситуацію якимось
чином вплинути на Я Хочу уточнити Я маю
написати наприклад тобто те що я можу
контролювати з точки зору тих страхів
які я написала пари так не дивлячись на
те що страх є от ви Прописали да якусь
ситуацію але зараз подумайте що можливо
вам просто потрібно щось якісь додаткові
ресурси додатково підтримка можливо
консультація Можливо ще щось для того
щоб вирішити цю ситуацію
і якщо насправді пошукати серед оти х
думок які нас тривожать точно є те що
залежить від нас однозначно Є ситуації
які від нас не залежать але щось таки ми
можемо контролювати і це важливо
усвідомлювати
Так я тут так коротенько написала добре
друге коло ширше подумайте будь ласка
зараз про ті ситуації які можливо
напряму ви вирішите не можете але ви
можете впливати на них опосередковано
і третє коло - Це ті думки Це ті
ситуації швидше за все ситуація на які
ми Вплинути не можемо які поза нашим
контролем
так знову ж таки я Нагадую що на цю
вправу треба набагато більше часу так
просто ми так знаєте хочемо трішки і
писати і ділитися і показати якими
техніками можна скористатися
і якщо би я попросила вас поділитися Ну
просто можливо якісь думки виникали під
час того коли ви виконували цю вправу
якісь можливо ідеї
Ну насправді Коли я писала свої ось ці
тривоги від коли ми тільки починали цю
вправу і думаю можливо ідея така що
важливо потім цю кожну тривогу розкласти
на менші етапи Бо насправді є з
конкретної тривоги наприклад вибирала
якусь частину де є справді можу впливати
і
мені здається що воно тоді знаєте не так
страшно Тобто ми починаємо якусь одне
речення розкладати на на більші речення
Вони стають все меншими і знову ж таки
Навіть те що ми це прописуємо обдумуємо
різні варіанти рішення Де я можу
впливати А де не можу впливати це також
знижує рівень тривоги і страж так і коли
ми виконуємо в тренінговому форматі ось
таку от вправу то дуже багато чуємо від
учасників навіть такі висловлювання про
те що я навіть знаю з чого розпочати або
я там зараз вибудувала
за чим я можу робити Тобто це повертає
нас з отого стану безпомічності коли
здається що я не можу нічого
контролювати зараз це притаманно тому що
ми постійно в цій тривозі ми постійно в
стресі і коли ми фокусуємо свою увагу
виключно на тому що залежить від нас і
що ми можемо робити це справді є таким
дуже помічним ніж постійно крутити в
голові думку стосовно того що що ми не
можемо контролювати так миначе беремо
ситуацію в свої руки Так та повертаємо
собі оцей контроль бо сьогодні наша
щоденне життя не завжди від нас залежить
Так Дуже цінно дякую Дорогі колеги
надіюся що ви також з нами пишете
міркуєте і рефлексуєте так ну і ви так
націлили на те що добре було б якісь
справи розповісти які можна час від часу
робити і є якісь техніки які Ну як
швидка якась допомога для того щоби
впоратися з якимись емоційними
переживаннями
І ми теж можемо зараз декілька з них
зробити а зробити виконати так і
безумовно такою швидкою допомогою для
нас І це те що не потребує якихось
додаткових ресурсів та це та пігулка яка
постійно з нами це наше дихання так всі
ми про це знаємо Не знаємо але рідко
виконувати але Повірте це дуже помічним
і кожна дихальна вправа Мабуть я
розповім а потім можемо спробувати
виконати Вона починається з заземлення
тому ми спочатку маємо сісти так щоби
відчувати опору під собою і Зверніть
увагу що стілець надійно тримає ваше
тіло можна відчути ногами підлогу і
будь-яка вправа на дихання вона
розпочинається з видиху це важливо Чому
Тому що коли ми робимо Спочатку видих ми
набираємо рівно стільки повітря скільки
потрібно нашим легеням для
функціонування ми в дихаємо повітря
через ніс видихаємо через рот і
основний в техніці - це те що видих має
бути довшим ніж наш гріх ну можемо
спробувати давай зробити і так робимо
вдих видих спочатку вибачте
і можете продовжувати дихати
нагадаю що це та із найпростіших вправ
коли ми концентруємо увагу на своєму
диханні яка може нас заспокоїти може
повернути нам стану цей спокою при
тривозі при страхах при навіть злості
коли ми зараз розгнівані і бачимо
відчуваємо якесь Роздратування Хочеться
кричати
найпростіше чим ми можемо зараз
підтримати себе це нашим диханням ну
дихати ще важливо теж
комусь навіть доводиться
перенавчатися тому що можна покласти
одну руку на грудну клітину одну на
живіт подихайте зараз своєму темпі і
відчуйте якою частиною взагалі ви
дихаєте яка рука дуже поверхнева
поверхнево власне оце поверхневе дихання
це те що ми вже набули в процесі нашої
життєдіяльності для нас природній спосіб
дихання для тих людей це якраз дихання
животом коли ви подивитесь на маленьку
дитину там до уроку да рік ви побачите
що дитина дихає якраз з животом те що ми
дихаємо верхньою частиною да грудьми це
вже те чого ми набули в процесі наших
життя діяльності і це наш такий
природний спосіб дихання чому важливо
дихати животом тому що ми активізуємо
наш блукаючий нерв які дає сигнал нашому
мозку про те що зі мною все нормально да
Я в безпеці і можна знову ж таки
спочатку провести ось таку невеличку
діагностику для того щоб відчути
все-таки якої частиною Я дихаю і потім
якщо Повірте дуже багатьом людям
доводиться перенавчати себе дихати Тобто
ми можемо дихати животом на постійній
основі може так ага
От і а власне
можете да покласти руки Зараз на живіт
точно так робимо спочатку видих
і навдосі
ніби як кулька всередині нас надувається
і знову такі видих А коли ми підключаємо
ще
верхню частину Коли нам потрібні більші
об'єми повітря та ми справляємося з
якоюсь там
навантаженням якимось фізичними і так
далі взагалі нормальний такий природній
спосіб дихання Для нас це дихання живота
тому можна теж взяти як такий інструмент
для того щоб напрацювати таку навичку
для себе дуже-дуже корисно найкраще що
ми можемо її виконувати будь-коли і
будь-де А так і хочеться підтримати тих
у кого спочатку не виходить Тому що як
будь-яка навичка для того щоб вона
сформувалася потрібно просто тренуватися
і це можна відводити там хай це буде 2-3
хвилини але декілька разів на день і ви
помітите що власне у вас виходить
набагато краще і
головне відслідковувати стан що ви
подихали вам стало спокійніше йдете собі
працювати далі І все з вами гаразд Ну
насправді сьогодні дуже багато різних
джерел звідки можна брати і тілесні
вправи різні Ми наприклад в садочку
виконуємо обов'язково з дітьми і ввели
навіть такий новий елемент ранкового
кола і ранковому колі В нас обов'язково
є дихальні вправи є тілесні вправи дуже
гарно ідея до речі Дорогі колеги а серед
тілесних такою дуже простою є Ну мабуть
метелик Обійми метелика вже Знають всі
але мені дуже подобається вправа Коли ми
можемо по черзі стискати кулачки один
інший один інший і теж от Навіть зараз
коли я
розмовляю з вами зрозуміло що певне
хвилювання воно є але от зараз відчуваю
як ну от навіть м'язи обличчя і взагалі
як моє тіло зараз реа коли я виконую цю
вправу стає набагато спокійніший легше і
я відчуваю що навіть голос по-іншому
звучить Тому це теж такий дуже простий
інструмент який постійно з нами будь
ласка беріть застосовуйте і пам'ятайте
про те що ось ця аптечка швидкої такої
допомоги для того щоб стабілізувати
власний стан у нас завжди з нами
направду це вправа якась Чарівна то я
теж відчуваю як мені стає спокійніше І
знаєте мені здається що в тривозі
дорослі часто зразу беруть в руки
телефон і починають гортати свій стрічку
бо начебто не має часу якось по-іншому
себе заспокоїти але це є значно дієвіше
і простіше і що важливо корисніше ну і
ще секрету таких от різних вправ Метелик
і ось з цими потисканнями кулачків тому
що саме Ось ця тривожність Вона в нас
знижується а підвищується якийсь отакий
проживання якихось позитивних таких от
емоцій Тобто це не тільки звуки ми
можемо там пригадувати згадувати якісь
приємні моменти і це теж таким є
дуже-дуже помічним дуже дякую
так як себе заспокоїти ми розібралися а
тепер давайте перейдемо вже до тих кого
нам потрібно підтримувати кожного дня до
нас усіх дітей Бо знаєте насправді діти
які перебувають в кризі або в стресі
по-різному може від рефлексовувати цей
досвід хтось може озвучити якщо вже вміє
говорити
і в принципі розуміє свої емоції от
хтось наприклад починає плакати хтось
шукає обійми тулиться до рідних але
бувають діти які закривають це і жодним
чином не проявляють того що вони і в
стресі і це як на мене є такий дуже
важливий сигнал з якими маємо працювати
Тому що важливо всім дітям допомогти і
аби всі діти проживали досвід і свої
емоції по суті викидали назовні так які
є накопичилися як ми можемо допомогти
дітям які можливо є вправи ігри техніки
для дітей аби вони знімали з себе у цю
внутрішню напругу
Ну мабуть перш ніж говорити вправи якісь
та важливо озвучити якісь такі загальні
підходи підтримки дитини в різних
емоційних станах тому що насправді і
дорослі і діти Зараз переживають цілу
палітру різних емоцій і
власне дитина Найперше що вона має
відчувати поряд із дорослим що зі мною
все гаразд і що не дивлячись які в мене
зараз там Да Зі мною все нормально і що
дитина в безпеці саме ось цю
нормальність і оцю безпечність дає саме
дорослий стійкий дорослий яким чином
важливо нормалізувати те що дитина
наприклад зараз вона з литься на щось да
або вона сумує зараз сильно що ми робимо
ми присідаємо до дитини ми говоримо про
те що я бачу що ти злишся зараз бувають
Так ми не тільки визнаємо ми даємо да
право їм проявитися це по-перше А це про
прийняття дитини
своїй стані Якій зараз є друге - це про
цю нормалізацію стану ми ще й кажемо про
те що бувають моменти коли я теж злюсь і
Якщо ви готові поділитися в яких
ситуаціях це буде тільки Здорово але
завдавати шкоду собі чи іншим Ми не
можемо і таким чином ми розмежовуємо
емоції дитини і її поведінку і дитина
відчуває що а тим більше коли дорослий
звучить що я теж буваю злюся Да вона вже
для неї це сигнал що зі мною все
нормально тому що і мама з лиця і
вихователь злиться але вона чітко
розуміє що А є поведінка якою ми
управляємо Да і тоді пункт оцього
управління він в наших руках
безумовно якщо навіть там потрібно
зупинити дитину от ну бувають же між
дітьми якісь сутички там одна дитина
піднімає іграшку хоче вдарити іншу і
можна навіть фізично затримати не
смикати дитину але фізично піймати Ручку
дай сказати що я бачу як ти злишся що
тобі Сергі стукнути хочеться тобто
Зупинити цю реакцію Зупинити цю реакцію
назвати емоцію тому що в такий спосіб ми
ще і навчаємо дітей озвучувати ці
емоційні переживання як це називається
те що я зараз відчуваю це розвиток по
суті емоційного інтелекту дитини так
Просто насправді е-е такі підвалиними
закладаємо Так але вправляємо дитину в
тій же поведінці ми можемо навчати дітей
і маємо навчати дуже таким простим знову
ж таки технікам як ми можемо
відреагувати Гнів і дуже добре коли
вихователі наприклад в колі Вони
поговорять з дітьми про емоції і
наголосять на тому що немає хороших і
поганих емоцій ви подивіться в нас по
сьогоднішній день до нині можна зустріти
фразу там про те що позитивні негативні
емоції кожна емоція вона для чогось нам
Дана і важлива вона важлива цій потрібні
так і ми можемо навіть Ну залежності від
віку дітей якщо це старший дошкільник то
чому не розповісти чи середня навіть
група про те що наприклад в емоції
злості дуже багато енергії і це та
енергія яка допомагає нам а захищатися б
долати якісь перешкоди але є поведінка і
от поведінку ми вже обираємо поведінка
чарівниці і коли ми поговорили про
емоції про те саме злість ми можемо
техніки виконати з дітьми в колі і
наприклад у нас в групах є така Чарівна
скринька діти з нею знайомі дає чарівні
речі за допомогою яких ми можемо цей
Гнів відреагувати що там є там є
паперовий стаканчик який ми можемо
викричати з лісі робимо це разом із
вихователем я собі готова вже записувати
дуже класно йти там є подушечка яку ми
можемо зараз побити разом так для того
щоб вихід цей цих всі емоції відбувся
там може бути е-е папір і олівці де ми
можемо
вималювати зараз все що відчуваємо
підібрати для цього колір і дитина може
це вималювати викричати побити подушку
ми можемо запропонувати елементарне
папір який ми можемо зараз поміняти і
звичайно добре знайомити з техніками не
тоді Вже коли дитина там злиться та А ми
спочатку пояснюємо розповідаємо і ми так
ніби як інтегруємо оці от стратегії
повсякденну діяльність дитини так
готуємо готуємо або елементарна дитина
Ми знайомимо з тим що коли ти гніваєш це
можна попити теплу воду маленькими
ковточками да І це техніка теж і для
дорослих абсолютно яка заспокоює і і
допомагає тому наголошуємо що кожна
емоція є важлива
як дорослий підтримує і це не тільки
злості в нас є діти які сумують
сумують через те що можливо там частина
родини залишилась на окупованій
території чи тато зараз на фронті і
важливо теж розуміти життєву ситуацію
дитини і бути поряд отим дорослим які
готовий розділити з нею цей сум і
сказати про те що я бачу як ти сумуєш
зараз можна запропонувати дитині
намалювати сумного героя чи навіть
сумного смайлика і запитати про те як ти
думаєш що йому допоможе або як ми можемо
покращити його стан що може бути таким
помічним для нього і дитина може
озвучити насправді вона озвучує те як би
вона хотіла щоб про неї потурбувались
зараз тому Для нас це Іще такі підказки
будь ласка Так чого дитина зараз
потребує яка її потреба і ми можемо
використовувати це в своїй роботі знаєте
що хотіла додати
нам діти часто можуть засмучуватися
через якісь на нашу думку незначні речі
і ми дорослі самі цього не бажають Чи
можемо сказати Та нічого страшного Та
чого ти плачеш це дрібниця знаєте діти ж
можуть почати плакати через якусь зі
жмякану серветку яку вони забули вдома
але тут дуже важливо не знецінювати те
що дитина плаче боїться важливо і для
неї зараз це серветочка найважливіше в
житті і от прийняте дитину такої якої
вона є з її емоціями сказати я розумію
чому ти засмучуєшся і Чому ти плачеш так
Це найтика поширеніша помилка дорослого
і знову ж таки мені хочеться підтримати
батьків тому що Зрозуміло вони це
роблять чи там інших дорослих які
піклуються про дитину бо вони це роблять
із великої любові до дитини насправді
вони хочуть огородити дитину від якихось
там таких переживань і не думають про те
що вони насправді можуть там знецінювати
зараз це те що дитина відчуває говорити
тобі одне за що переживати
втішання так і вони це роблять з великою
любов'ю Але знову ж таки Важливо
пам'ятати що коли ми такі речі
проговорюємо то це для дитини сигнал про
те що не важливо взагалі що зі мною
зараз відбувається або це може звучати
як отака заборона на все те що я зараз
відчуваю і це теж Ну не не зовсім добре
Так можливо дуже себе ловити на цьому бо
ми інколи в найкращих наших побажаннях і
поривах можемо ненароком нашкодити
Добренько рухаємося далі
так так Зараз і в мене ще є тут
запитання
які вправи на стежня і на заземлення
можемо використати з дітьми але може
почнемо з того що таке стеження що таке
заземлення
ну заземлення це якраз от така техніка
яка допомагає знову ж таки і
стабілізувати наш сам і
насправді насправді вони можуть бути
дуже-дуже простими навіть оце
елементарне проговорювання яке щойно ми
з вами робили Да що відчуєте зараз що
надійно стілець тримає ваше тіло
відчуйте зараз опору під ногами можна
дітям запропонувати коли ми відчули
опору під ногами піджимати пальчики
давайте виконаємо таку вправу або
позабивати уявні такі цвяшки п'яточками
це те що допомагає нам злитися навіть
обпертися об стінку відчути оцю опору це
те що допомагає навчання
заземлитися і
навіть коли ми працюємо дистанційно І це
дуже добре коли ми будемо виконувати
отакі от вправи на заземлення і якісь
тілесні вправи До речі ми ще не сказали
про тілесні вправи це дуже Хочу
наголосити важливо коли ми працюємо в
такому онлайн форматі тому що ми
постійно бачимо в екрані свою голову
тільки першу половину першу половину
себе і обличчя інших дітей інших людей і
ніби як втрачаємо ось цей контакт з
власної тілесністю тому дуже добре
заземлення дуже добре вправа там килимок
Коли ми можемо простукати все своє тіло
і я там використовую і пояснюю чому це
важливо тому що знову ж таки ми Таким
чином повертаємо собі ось цю тілесність
є хороша
орангутанг яка дуже подобається Так ми
робимо вдих і на видиху
Це я просто там мікрокреди нас на видиху
ми робимо звук я і
б'ємо кулачками по грудній кліткою
вправа яка дуже подобається і дорослий і
дітям і вона дітям піднімає настрій і
вона піднімає таку енергію і дитина
легше і активніше йде в те що ми зараз
пропонуємо виконати тому будь ласка
використовуйте дуже багато таких
техніків Правда є Світлана Рось за що і
дуже вдячна і цілі посібники з цими
вправами добре що зараз вони вже є
правда і виконуйте ці вправи разом з
дітьми Бо нам вони також не користь
правильно так добре А в мене ще питання
власне де шукати техніки вправи що можна
прочитати ви знаєте
там зараз в інтернеті дуже багато всього
але насправді надзвичайно важливо знайти
саме якісну інформацію яка не зашкодить
а допоможе де ми всі можемо знайти
інформацію підказки як допомогти дітям
як допомогти собі тощо ну найперше хочу
сказати про ті знову ж таки вже
літературні такі джерела які можна
використовувати і мені здається стільки
скільки зробила Світлана саме для дітей
дошкільного віку людей які працюють з
ними і для батьків тих же Ну дуже просто
так питання тому передаємо вітання так
справді А по-друге це дуже багато різних
навчань І наприклад я як тренер
всеукраїнського фонду крок за кроком Ми
з березня
2022 року проводимо такі навчання саме
для людей які працюють з дітьми
дошкільного віку і на сьогодні
підготовлено 20 тренерів національного
рівня
150 тренерів які працюють в регіонах
вони навчають саме вихователів
помічників вихователів ну тобто
колективи дошкільних закладів саме в
темі
психосоціальної підтримки Ну і хочу
сказати що зараз ми підготували два
відеокурси і вже вони готові до того щоб
можна було запропонувати всій моделі з
них з теми психосоціальної підтримки
якій розрахований на людей які можуть
навіть не мати педагогічної освіти Тобто
це така от підтримка для всіх біля кого
зараз є діти дошкільного віку це і для
батьків підходять для вихователів для
волонтерів для будь-кого для волонтерів
які працюють в якихось осередках де
просто діти приходять на якийсь час це
такі ну Найважливіші речі які зібрані в
одному курсі 12 відеолекцій і другий
курс він спрямований підготовлений саме
для вихователів
з теми психосоціальної підтримки нам 8
відео лекцій і додаткові матеріали до
кожної лекції для того щоб можна було
попрацювати з цим Ну і зазвичай Ми не
використовуємо цей як лекційний матеріал
як от ти зараз да А це якийсь техніки це
розмір кейсів коли можна проаналізувати
навіть в такому форматі подивитися що в
мене вже добре виходить А де можливо я
подивлюсь на свою практику дещо під
іншим кутом і є щось Що я точно захочу
змінити після того коли дізнався тобто
все абсолютно практично
Я дуже рада насправді що ми сьогодні
Поговорили на цю тему Дорогі колеги ми
до речі пізніше надійшла Ми весь перелік
всіх матеріалів Тобто ми тут не просто
проговорили і заводили ми обов'язково з
вами поділимося бо Насправді те що ми
робимо Сьогодні ми
закладаємо дуже довгостроково інвестицію
в наших дітей в наше майбутнє і власне в
свій психологічний стан також
Я думаю можемо прощатися Дякую за увагу
дякую за запрошення Дякую усі тримаємось
До побачення
[музика]
ще раз Доброго дня дорогі колеги ми вже
переходимо до такого більшої зустрічі до
більшого формату і Зараз у нас буде
свого роду панель на дискусія але
насправді ми не будемо дискутувати ми
будемо ділитися своїм досвідом будемо
ділитися різними можливостями для
вихователів і для батьків в тому числі і
я хочу представити всіх наших спікерів
Отож з нами сьогодні Анастасія
Коновалова фахівчення з дошкільної
освіти дитячого фонду ООН юнісе в
Україні Світлана Тарабарова співачка
композиторка багатодітна мама Олена
Попова Монтессорі педагогиня експертка з
усвідомленого батьківства авторка безліч
чи книг для батьків та бетагів і також
багатодітна мама і Олександр Гавриленко
координатор Еллі стартер з International
в Україні а також член освітнього класру
групи дошкілля Дорогі колеги Вітаю вас
тут дуже дякуємо всім дізналися до нас
онлайн Тепер давайте перейдемо до суті
не будемо говорити про довгі вступи Бо
знаєте немає часу адже повномасштабна
війна вимагає від нас дуже швидких
кроків швидких дій і я би хотіла
розпочати з того що у зв’язку з воєнним
станом в Україні дошкільна освіта дещо
змінилася дещо
деформувалася і ми освітяни дуже швидко
маємо реагувати на всі ті виклики які
перед нами постають і перше моє питання
стосується альтернативних форм
дошкільної освіти Я хочу його поставити
Анастасії оскільки юнісеф якраз
займається альтернативним фолом
дошкільної освіти і питання полягає в
тому які саме альтернативні форми
дошкільної освіти з'явилися в Україні за
час повномасштабної війни Можливо ми про
якісь не знаємо і всім нам варто
дізнатися своє ім'я впевнена що ти таки
знаєш Але кому Варто знати звичайно дуже
радо Поділюсь а дійсно досвід України
унікальний і зараз про наші
альтернативні моделі дошкільного
Навчання вже говорить весь світ сьогодні
маємо досить вдалій моделі які успішно
імплементовані у місцях де немає доступу
до очного навчання для діток зокрема це
модель змішаного навчання Коли ми онлайн
поєднуємо з зустрічами з педагогами і
вони також поєднуються з домашнім
навчанням тобто батькам допомагають
організувати домашнє завдання для цього
розроблені зокрема розроблена платформа
Нумо для дошкільнят а далі
працюють педагоги в місцях де це
безпечно працюють двічі на тиждень по
дві години І тут вже дуже комплексно
підходять для кожної дитини тому що на
сході дуже важко дітям в першу чергу і
там вже педагогів тренують і
психологічні підтримці і звертати увагу
на якісь як ми кажемо червоні флажки Це
перша така модель змішаного навчання
далі
оскільки в нас дуже креативні освітяни
то кожна область кожна громада
імплементує свої моделі зокрема в
Дніпропетровській області
пілотуються модель мобільного садочку де
виїжджаю освітня команда і працює з
дітками те що віддалених районах там де
це безпечно де це можна зробити може
бути навіть шелтері працюють постійно
є в Одещині моделі півдня коли дітки на
пів дня на 3 години ходять тобто в
принципі будь-яка можливість коли діти
очно збираються і граються та така
фасилітована гра при тому батьки
отримують підтримку як організувати
розвиток дитини в домашніх умовах оце
все чому нас навчила війна на жаль але
ми цей досвід перенесемо йому ще висвіт
навчимо абсолютно я з вами згідно Бо
насправді навіть оце ідея мобільних
садків як на мене це чудова ідея яку ми
можемо якою ми можемо поділитися світом
і всі кого ця модель зацікавить або хто
її потребує в різних громадах можуть
навіть скористатися насправді знаєте оці
альтернативні форми дошкільної освіти це
їх такі пазлики які допомагають нам
забезпечувати якісне навчання але радше
я тут скажу просто зростання дитини ви
знаєте навчання в дошкіллі це воно таке
опосередковане найважливіше або дитина
могла соціалізуватися в середовищі і
власне коли ми говоримо про
альтернативні форми в будь-якому випадку
Чи це вдома дистанційно чи це в садочку
чи це якийсь волонтерський ініціативи
дитина десь перебуває в якомусь просторі
Я якраз хотіла би запитатися про простір
і в мене тут питання до Олександра бо
ваша організація якраз працює над
створення безпечних просторів і я знаю
що вже з'явилася кілька таких просторів
в Україні Що саме має бути у просторі
або ми могли його називати безпечно не
важливо наприклад нехай це буде не
тільки дитячий садок а в тому числі
дистанційна освіта чи вдома коли батьки
з дітьми самостійно займаються тощо
почну з словами Яна моса каменнського
Кожна дитина має бути щасливою бо вона
має на це право і наша організація
International займається батьма
напрямками зокрема створення яку
зазначили пані Соломія безпечних
просторів для дітей що це таке Це не
просто укриття чи підвал чи безпечну
територію це
атмосфера в першу чергу Ми створюємо
атмосферу коли дитина приходить в цей
простір і Вона почуває себе безпечно як
вдома ми працюємо із викликами і з
військовими викликами в багатьох
територіях країнах і спочатку збройної
агресії Росії почали працювати саме в
Україні і є допомоги українським
військовим тимчасового переміщеними
особам які живуть і в Україні і за
кордоном ми відкрили 5 кімнат в Чехії в
Польщі в
кишеневій Молдові для того щоб допомогти
нашим людям які постраждали внаслідок
збройної агресії почати себе нормально
щоб діти розвивалися відчували себе
українцями і в Україні Ми почали
відкривати кімнати з самого початку
озброєних агресій збореної навали
російської але тут є специфіка кожна
кімната в Україні вона відрізняється
тому що по-перше дуже різні люди дуже
різна ментальність і дуже різний стан
дітей саме головне щоб наші кімнати діти
почували себе дійсно комфортно безпечно
і були щасливими і наша основна Місія -
це зробити так щоб дитина сама формувала
цей простір яким чином наприклад У нас є
кімната у Львові у Києві і тут показово
вже є результати коли діти які переїхали
із території де ведуться бойові дії
почувають себе дійсно щасливими і вони
як правильно визначили соціалізуються
тому що є колектив є вихователі є
психологи працюють і з дітьми із
батьками і батьками тому що ну не так
просто все ми говоримо про дітей але ми
пам'ятаємо що основне акцент на батьків
тому що діти змальовують картинку саме
своїх батьків і величезна роль
вихователів тому щоби створити сукупну
сферу щоб діти спочатку йшли за
вихователем тобто Ми створюємо
індивідуальну траєкторію виховну а вже
потім самі формували і самі говорили що
їм класно що їм заходить Що Їм цікаво і
чим вони будуть займатися і наша кімнати
по-перше вони мають бути поблизу або
укртів або укриттях створені а по-друге
діти мають розуміти чітко що тут вони
захищені і фізично і ментально їх ніколи
не давить ніхто не заставляє Нічого вони
самі мають свою траєкторію
освітньо-виховно створювати разом
зхватиме і психологами і Це штука дуже
цікава Я до речі дуже вдячний тут є
представник Монтессорі Тому що наші ідеї
вони мабуть в одному руслі і в одному
напрямку тому що дитина для того щоб
вона розвивалася щоб вона отримала
поштовх інтелектуальний Вона має перш за
все бути спокійною і щасливою тоді вона
зможе відсторнутися бази від цієї
платформи і далі вже ну розвиватися так
як і великі і серце і так як її хочеться
як вона може далі вже йдуть здібності
далі ждуть навчання освітні траєкторії
але перш за все Ми створюємо оцю
платформу базу і сьогодні у нас активно
розвивається кімнати у Сумах у
кропивницькому у Рівному і кожний
кімната має абсолютно своє значення свій
напрямок якщо у кропивницькому В нас
дуже багато
внутрішнього переміщених осіб ну на
там один підхід то у Рівному наприклад
це діти з інклюзією будуть у Сумах Самі
розумієте так само як і в Харкові то теж
надо будується Там не дуже небезпечно
тому що бойові дії ведуться поряд і діти
теж мають інший стрес але наша кімната
наш простір безпечний покликаний саме
зробити універсальну таку модель коли
діти мають бути не в стресі а спокої і в
комфорті для того щоб розвиватися і
щасливими Дякую дуже Олександр і ви так
гарно якраз мені зробили підводку до
наступного питання до Олени от знаєте
перед тим як поставити Це питання Я
трішки прокоментую або ми перед тим
говорили з психологиною пані Інною про
те що дітям зараз дуже важливо повернути
певну стабільність їхнє життя і
насправді що діти можуть контролювати в
дитинстві це свою гру це те як вони
спілкуються з однолітками це те як вони
перебувають в дитячому просторі і ця
стабільність і це їхня гра якою вони
керують Я якраз стою опорою для дітей і
от власне говорячи про Монтессорі підхід
які вправи техніки ідеї з методики
Монтессорі ми можемо використати у всіх
дитячих садках що і такого важливого Ми
кажемо про те що
гра не необхідна для дитини Але монсурі
методі ми використовуємо слово робота
сидити ходять і працюють тому що це
дійсно здійснюється дуже велика робота
перед собою внутрішнім чим менша дитина
тим вона дітки до трьох років вони
взагалі будують свою особистість і дуже
важливо і чим відрізняються Монтессорі
садочки да діти які там виховуються вони
дуже самостійні дуже багато роботи від
самого початку іде на практичне життя
тобто все що можна надягнути
перелити
пересипати да все те що батьки бояться
іноді давати вдома тому що О боже
скільки прибирання буде Да мама на
боїмося але от ну зараз дуже багато йде
усвідомлених батьків коли і я часто кажу
що якщо це вдома це Кухня це найбільший
взагалі напрямок діяльності що можна
зробити бо можна давати і на сенсорні
відчуття Да там холодне гаряче мокре
сухе і це саме ми можемо в просторі
давати поняття ці всі важкі легкі брудне
чисте це все практичне життя яке нас
[музика]
це все практичне життя яке нас оточує І
це ми можемо давати в класі це перше
взагалі що йде тобто у Монтессорі методі
Ми кажемо про те що найбільше зона
практичного життя це якраз там в
толлерах від двох до трьох рочків І
найліпше що можна дати наприклад клас в
класі вже центівки для прибирання це
віночок совочок поставити смітник Да
куди можна викидати сміття це може бути
невеличка швабра І взагалі монтезорі
класи найчастіше класи можна сказати До
речі на замітку і вихователям і батькам
вдома тому що ми навчаємо у дітей є
період чутливості до порядку якщо ми в
цей період влучно покажемо дітям як ми
можемо використовувати ці засоби то
потім не буде запитань Взагалі що ви не
можете користуватися що ви тут розкидали
бо вони будуть знати да є принципи
базові які ми використовуємо ти взяв з
місця Погрався Постав будь ласка на
місце Та прибери за собою підготуй
простір для наступної дитини такий самий
то це ну елементарно але те що дуже
дієво До речі відповідальності Я
пропустила цей період у свою дитину
ну Зазвичай це починається ні Після
восьми там шести восьми років батьки
починають А ти там не вмієш перебирати
що таке або втрачений оцей період коли
була чутливість саме до цього Чому ми
кажемо да про дошкілля
найважливіший період створення людини от
самій в собі це є період до 6 років
Тобто Це не для того щоб перетримати
дитину в
просторі якомусь до того щоб дитина до
росла до школи і в школі Її навчать ні
от саме в цей період найважливіше для
того щоб дитина
напрацювала людину доросло в собі
Скажімо так і всі навички які їй
потрібні Дякую дуже до слова ті хто
дистанційно або змішано відвідують
садочок також може скористатися цими
підходами бо кухня може бути і творчістю
для дитини і тут Ми якраз можемо ці
експерименти провести за допомогою
батьків і опікунів правильно те що я
кажу мама в найкраща це от готувати
разом з дитиною да оце най- Ну в мене
такий наприклад борщ називається да Коли
ми накидали всіх овочів що можна
поставили дитину поруч є там стілець
вежа вам кажемо Монтессорі але ну для
багатодітної мами Табуретка теж
але важливо просто бути поруч за
забезпечувати цю безпеку не кидали всі
овочі ми показуємо ми називаємо Тобто ми
даємо мовні поняття що це саме таке і
дитина це може потримати в руках от оце
морква оце картопля оце цибуля потім ми
це показуємо що це брудне миємо ми воду
можемо дати тепла холодна гаряча
комфортно не комфортна такі поняття
даємо потім помили потім починаємо
чистити О Боже картопля коричнева стала
біла да то менше ми Ріжемо це було ціле
а стало частинками даємо дитині
перекладати Тобто вона вже задіяна вона
дав може це робити рукою може це робити
ложкою можна змінювати тарілочки дається
все кажемо от сюди сюди і потім Це ще
варимо Туди вже не допускаємо дитину да
газ гаряче але вона може спостерігати на
безпечній дистанції можемо показувати
етапи приготування і це можна робити там
вже умовно з року дитини і вона все буде
ці навички набувати от тому те що
вдається в класі це практичне життя
повертаючись та туди сенсорні відчуття
всі на те щоб понюхати пощупати
послухати навіть чути тактильні відчуття
і розвиток дрібної моторики крупної
моторики Це все можна робити і вдома і в
класі але на цьому це така база і основа
яка дається І ми тоді Монтессорі в першу
чергу Дякую дуже Олено я від одної
багатодітної мами прийду до іншої
Світлани Скажіть будь ласка у вас троє
дітей всі різного віку правильно на троє
дітей які ваші власні такі лайфхаки таке
популярне слово топ методи топ ресурси
якими ви користуєтеся від початку по
масштабної війни поділіться будь ласка з
нами от До речі методом Монтессорі Я
почала
Несвідомо користуватись тому що мені
багато чого будинку треба було і
приготувати І помити і погратися і я
зрозуміла що я не встигаю і Іван йому
зараз 5 років а десь йому було два роки
він почав вже активно бігати ходити десь
з рочку Я почала його долучати він мені
і під Богом мив йому була весело це було
найвеселіше заняття аніж погратися
машинкою і всі бачать я постійно
викладаю в своєму блозі в Інстаграмі як
ми готуємо разом я отримую таку
кількість коментарів Боже Світлана ви не
боїтесь такий бруд я постійно відповідаю
ми разом прибираємо І дійсно дітям
цікаво взяти гончірку і прибирати цікаво
за собою оцей період створення Це
неймовірно і всім мамочки всі батьки які
зможуть знайти в собі терпіння на
власній кухні разом з думками щось
створити це безцінно це магія А що до
мене Насправді
я так сиджу аналізую чим я можу
поділитися і я знайшла чим я можу
поділитися
коли я народила Івана 5 років тому ми
свідомо в
побуті Я з Херсону в мене російськомовна
родина була все життя чоловік з Києва
так само На жаль але коли в нас
народилися Діти ми свідомо перейшли
по-перше на українську в побуті всюди Ми
вирішили що наші діти будуть зростати
тільки так і ми разом з ними будемо
вчитися до чого я це Веду до того що
матеріалу пісень музики віршів книжок
було не так багато зараз вже Слава Богу
неймовірна кількість аудіоказок
які є і телеграм-канали безкоштовні якщо
ви втомлюєтеся не можете можемо читати
самостійно на допомогу приходить в
аудіоказка далі музика Коли ти постійно
тоном дитині повторюєш давай чистити
зуби давай вмиватися кожен день вони вже
як блок вони вже не чують І що я
вирішила зробити написати веселі пісні
на цю тему я написала дитячі альбом
будучи з поліною животику дітки
допомагали ми написали Не просто музику
а
методичку твого дня
Ви ЗНО змогли це потім протестувати вже
разом зі своїми дітьми правильно мої
діти напам'ять знають що чистий мозуби
вмиваємося і вони це роблять рухами
настрій одразу покращується і ще й
психологічно я вклала в ті пісні що
Вибір за тобою твій настрій - це твій
вибір ти можеш просунувати можеш в тебе
є на це право але навіщо якщо Життя
прекрасне ну інколи інколи коли на
бабахкає за вікном тобто музика свій
лайфхак я можу запропонувати музику якщо
це весело це завжди підіймає настрій це
завжди знімає напругу стрес адже що є
помітила коли мої діти почали ходити в
садочок Я помітила що вони там дуже
втомлюються
насправді є такий мінус що зараз
особливо
в якихось там приватних садочках
навантаження на дітей величезне і я прям
прошу будь ласка не треба їм 150 занять
підряд просто поспілкуйтесь з ними нехай
пограється на килимку Так ось я помітила
що вони приходять втомлені
До чого це я вела забула
пісня ритм так так знімаєш стрес знімаєш
стрес бо навіть відриву не можуть
втомитися що ще допомагає мені в свій
час юнісепт створили платформі numo
неймовірний ляльковий театр хочу про
нього розповісти бо я вже не можу Моя
дитина просто знає напам'ять всі оці так
само це дивитися робити вони в мене
самостійно вже роблять це театр який
називається іскорки запалюють суперсили
нас юнісеф з ним познайомив і ми
роздрукували всі ці штуки ви можете
безкоштовно роздрукувати на сайті І так
само зі своїми дітками і в укритті і
просто в просторі і на вулиці просто на
лавочці ви можете теж грати через героїв
діти дізнаються простих правильних
звичок і це дуже круто Та ми співати і
грати і як знаходити спільну мову з
іншими дітками Бо насправді Це теж є
проблемою зараз у багатьох наших дітей
ну класний я вам дуже дякую за театр ви
обов'язково хто нас бачить хто чує Якщо
ви ще не знали завантажте послу
хайте музику разом з дітками що ще
головне
головне знаходити сили батькам опікунам
вихователям
знаходити сили бути
гарною людиною адже навчити без власного
досвіду дуже важко треба бути гарною
людиною а діти підтягнуться там правда
ми насправді навчаємо власним прикладом
І знаєте якими би словами вкладали але
те як ми потім відтворюємо Саме цей
щитують Діти Це справді дуже важливо До
речі Дорогі колеги ми такі знаєте зараз
зробимо паузу тут в розмові і бо до нас
підключилися наша колега
Мер'єм Александрова з садочку в Ізраїлі
і Міріам Вона працює в садочку
нам цікаво наприклад було би дізнатися А
які такі є техніки вправи ігри бо в
сьогоднішню наша зустріч - Це абсолютно
про практику
який ми можемо використати і тут в
Україні мір'ян Добрий день
я приїхала до Ізраїлю на після
повномасштабного вторгнення я не жила
тут усе життя Я жила у Дніпрі Я
народилася у Дніпрі і дуже сумую І так
тут дещо змінена і те що відрізняється
система виховання і система освіти
по-перше я це побачила і на своїх дітях
У мене є двоє діточок старша моя
дівчинка вона ходить у ізраїльський
дитячий садочок на початку була дуже
важка депортація тому що її мовний
бар'єр і Треба було вчити і не було з
ким спілкуватися дітям і я хочу сказати
що перший рік у Ізраїлі Я працювала у
таких безпечних простірах про який
розповідав Олександр відтворює стартовий
International це простори які надають
сили дітям не тільки в Україні а й за
кордоном це люди які не дають дітям
друзів і саме завдяки такій безпечним
просторам можуть адаптуватися в Нових
умовах
про ізраїльський садочки я можу
розказати на досвід як мама що я бачу що
відбувається з моєї дитини по-перше моя
дівчинка вона ходить до садочку з
великим бажанням чому я у неї питаю Що
тобі так подобається там Ми кажемо Там
дуже багато граємо це про те що ми
казали що в Ізраїлі надають більше
свободи дітям і вся ініціатива іде від
дітей Вони хочуть будувати будинок
наприклад там 5 дітей Вони беруть усі
матеріали на подвір'ї почне збудувати
будинок до них долучається або помічник
вихователя або вихователь і вони
починають гру
город з цим будиночком про просторові
про просторові всі відношення на
підзовні
все що потрібно хто там живе хто може
жити а у вас буде будиночок
одноповерховий чи двоповерховий А де він
знаходиться потім вони починають
наприклад робити
казку з цього будиночку І от Ось так
вони роблять гру і це надає свободу
діткам це по-перше по-друге вони кожну
дитинку я називатися підсвічують вони
дають їй розкритися яким чином
за минулий рік Поки моя дівчинка була у
садочку в них була декілька проектів
року це проект на рік де вони кожній
дитині здавали свій час виступ по-перше
з ним був проект що кожного тижня кожна
дитина приносить плакат з фотографіями
дитини з самого дитячого віку і до
сьогодення крім того пишуть факти про
дитинку наприклад я полюбляю малювати я
полюбляю ходити на балет я полюбляю
грати у футбол Таким чином тільки
знайомляться бо тут кожного року трошки
змінюється склад групи
Таким чином всі батьки і всі дітки
бачать фотографії яка в них родина
Скільки дітей у родині тому що
багато-багато сімей багатодітніх від 3 і
4 якщо ви вже
увагу О Боже
жінки більше не дотягнула працюємо
це також був проект на рік
коли дітки приносили
з доньки страх і вони там підготували
однак дитинка приходила приносила
продукти показуємо що робити а інші
долучалися Наприклад ми робили піцу це
про кулінарію про практичні навички
ся
без не дала да В нас багато
і не треба потім наповнювали діти а
потім її змінити все це практично що
треба наприкінці року нам надали таку
папку де були
де були всі всі рецепти всі-всі рецепти
було і ми змогли щось приготувати Що
вони робили у садочку
вони також кожного тижня просили
принести щось з дому якісь речі за темою
тижня ніж дитина розповідала що у нього
є вдома з цієї теми тобто вони
розкривають дитину вони
до мітку переносять у садочок і це дуже
і таким чином створюють безпечне
середовище
та переношу сюди
Там більше свободи це так і тому діткам
там безпечніше і вони у цій грі вони
вчаться комунікувати їх не
дають їм таких рамок
ходить це не береться це по-перше
по-друге що мене дуже здивувало ми були
на святі в ізраїльському садочку
І ще я побачила що там не бояться
помилитися
тобто вони виходять на сцену навіть якщо
вони забули слова
іти і кажуть Вау Який ти Молодці Що ти
вийшов навести
кожна мама після
цього свята підійшла до своєї дитини
навіть якщо дитина взагалі не знала
пройти Вона відчула ти такий молодець Ми
так робимо да
що ти пишеш на сцену не було того а ти
забув слова а ти там буде пішов А чому
так було щоб кожна матуся вона стала ти
зірками просто зірка яку я обожнюю Ось
це те що мені здалося
незвичним в Ізраїлі
того чого я не очікувала тут побачити і
мені здається що це можливо дати і дітям
в Україні Це абсолютно можливо дати і
для цього лише знаєте потрібен особистий
ресурс Соня я хотіла додати от про
українські такий досвід оці розказують Я
згадала такий дуже цікавезний приклад
Одеської області
маленька гео не пам'ятаю як називається
але на них підписано вони орендували
автобус вони його дуже гарно
заклеїли Він такий ну автобус свято дуже
крутий Тобто він заїжджає прям сидіти
біжуть і вони їздять туди до закриті
садочки віддалені якісь райони а завжди
в один час тобто батьки мають це розклад
якийсь і починається все з того що Діти
заходять туди і реорганізуються автобус
і це прям дуже круто і вони ото беруть
там щось прибирають якось там
переставляють вони демонтували там
крісло там стоять якісь стільчики і далі
Ну дуже багато там організованих гри
звичайно Коли ти в автобусі ти не сидиш
в автобус Ну там ходять навколо автобус
називається це казкова подорож освітня
це дуже круто і я думаю Ну просто люди
взяли от самі да ну цей маленька го
організували автобус і катаються на
донати До речі тобто в них немає якогось
стало фінансування Я просто з ними
слідкую думаю Ну наскільки От наші
українські освітяни от от нема перешкод
бо простори да кімнати все одно це
ресурси тут тут мінімально ресурсів і Ну
дійсно десь як і не можна кімнату
організувати Вони завжди паркуються
автобус біля
бобмосховища Вони гуляють там навколо
автобуса бо десь сидять в автобусі Коли
погано погода і я от бачу там вони відео
знімають просто чер дітей вони вже
почали записувати Ну дійсно Круто І там
іскорки вони все-все використовують і
оце і в кінці обов'язково прибирається
автобуси розставляється так як було бо
автобус їде дальше до інших дітей тут
такий ну досвід дуже натхненний такий
приклад Да і маленький без фінансування
без нічого просто от знаєте і причому
вони збирають донати от зі всього світу
просто від персональних якихось донорів
і мені здається що це прям дуже такий
Цікавий приклад альтернативної освіти
насправді але от яка від якої дійсно
багато дітей отримуються так Бо
насправді знаєте це слово альтернативне
воно може включати в себе будь-що навіть
посидіти з дитиною там півгодини
поговорити але бути включеним бути тут
почути її це якраз це теж альтернативна
освіта і те що до речі мір'ян поділилася
з нами це не вимагає додаткового
фінансування це просто спілкуватися і чу
просто Спочатку треба переробити себе
позбутися від нашарування нашарувань
дитячих і дійсно от у нас наприклад є
правило коли ми приходимо додому ми не в
телефонах мені де ми з дітками ми
випускаємося на їх рівень і я чую все що
вони розповідають якщо нас не було вдома
і Вони діляться а їх ще двоє і вони
кричать перебивають потім он ще
починають битися Я сиджу і спостерігаю
Інколи просто навіть помовчати з ними
класно бо вони мають виговоритися досвід
який принести батьків або дім в школу у
нас в Монтессорі школі у дітей є така
практика коли батьки приходять провести
коло Тобто взагалі просто проведення
коло - це монтессорійський такий
міні-урок Який проводять вчителі але
запрошують батьків і батьки хто Що вміє
робити ті приходять тобто наприклад Ми з
чоловіком колись літали ми вдягали форму
приходили Радянській безпеки приносили
повністю все що на літаку ми розповідали
що це про що Навіщо Як ви думаєте що
робить тамбурпровідник на літаку така
була історія хтось у нас там пасічники
були вони приносили різні види меду соти
і все про виготовлення меду розповідали
хтось музичними інструментами приносили
туди і всі діти знають що І батьки ну
раз час від часу приходять і вони
дізнаються оце про
багатогранність розвитку особистості
коли дитина дізнається от з цього
малочку дуже-дуже багато всього це ну
такі уроки на які ми іноді коли батьки
писали списки ми такі обмеженими теж
прийдемо послухаєте клас Дякую що всіх
просто захоплююсь тому що Ну в мене одна
дитина донька я їх вже виховав вирости
від 25 років і зараз слухаючи номер Ям
що 34 дитини в Ізраїлі в кожного у нас
багатодітні мами я щиро ну поклоняюсь
тому що це подвиг в наш час підняти 3-4
дітей це справді подвиг І знаєте хочу
підтримати певний стан вона сказала дуже
вірні слова що не треба сподіватися на
вихователів вчителів тому що в них і так
навантаження величезне і дитина бере в
першу чергу приклад з кого з батьків
вона змальовує картинку те що бачить у
батьків і коли вона приходить в дитсадок
то вона просто транслює те що бачила
вдома відчула запам'ятала Це ті навички
це ті знання це Той досвід який вона
переносить і Саме тут всі праві про те
що соціалізація надзвичайно важливо коли
дитина Вона може поділитися своїм і
прийняти щось хороше в інших дітей і
вихователів і велика шана і подяка
вихователям тому що їх праця не оцінена
це взагалі ми говоримо про те що ми
говоримо про дошкілля про мого шкільний
вік від нуля до 8 років закладається і
формується людина тому що генетика дуже
важливо правда вихо освіта але
формування соціуму де знаходиться дитина
дуже важлива тому організаторів
International всім бажає Щоб ви всі
виховували якнайкращі своїх малят тому
що ну щиро якщо в нас 34 дитини То це
вже майбутнє для України є перспектива
що наша на
ція Україна буде жити щиро дякую До речі
у мене якраз буде питання наступне і до
Олени і до Олександра стосовно
простору так знову ж таки ми говоримо
про дуже різні формати нам зараз
потрібно максимально розширювати наше
уявлення про те Якою може бути дошкільна
освіта і яке ми може бути оце виховання
що має мати вмістити обов'язково простір
От наприклад там кілька елементів від
вас обох з поглядом Монтессорі і з
погляду безпечного простору
для того аби дитина почувалася в безпеці
ми вже почули мають бути фотографії
дитина має приносити щось вдома Тобто це
таке відчуття кола сім'ї а наприклад що
ще для того аби допомагати житі
стійкості дитини аби підтримувати її гру
можливо Подивіться будь ласка якщо ми
кажемо да про монсурі середовища і
взагалі про середовище для дитини яка Ну
для людини яка просто Да має низький
зріст то це перш за все низький меблі А
у нас там в класах батьки унітази Які
вбиральнях наприклад низькі рукомийники
можливість дитині самостійно прийти
тобто все організовано побутове таким
чином що дитина може це зробити сама да
низька лавочка вона прийшла сіла може
роззутися все облаштовано низьких
гачечки їй показують як це робиться і
Вона навчається це робити сама
показується процедури що
поступовістю ця да що ти прийшов тоді ти
йдеш мити руки то діти заходиш в клас в
класі все що для дитини воно в зоні
доступу тобто знову ж таки про низькі
меблі про полички які облаштовані Тобто
це підготовлене середовище для дитини
якщо ми кажемо для про дітей до трьох
років там бажано ще щоб було щось на
дуже багато руху тому що вони не можуть
в постійно сидіти тому наприклад в мене
класі є сходи гірка балансир тактильна
доріжка
тунель Тобто це все що протягом дня
можуть використовувати для того щоб
погрухатися І взагалі в нас облаштоване
середовище таким чином що ти маєш
забрати матеріал з полички піти сісти за
стіл або на килимочок попрацювати і
потім віднести назад тобто оця потреба в
Русі вона постійно реалізована
тому Ну от в облаштуванні саме
середовище я б казала наголошувала на
цьому щоб все створене для самостійності
дитини щоб вона змогла зробити все сама
вчитель Найбільше це презентує показує
як це робиться да доросле підготовлена
людина і потім дитина це повторює Дякую
дуже Олександр Ми живемо всі абсолютно
формати все що робив юнісеф Монтессорі і
наша реєстрація воно все перекликається
тому що ідеологія одна зробити дитину
щасливою спокійною врівноваженою і щоб
вона почувала себе безпечно є дуже
багато нюансів Мер'єм може сказала що є
такі фішки і в нашому просторах дуже
оскільки можемо поділитися наприклад
Скажіть будь ласка хто з вас в дитинстві
не грав у халабуду
мої діти двічі надають
дуже класна психічна штука коли людина
заходить в наш контубезпеки вперше все
ми дивимся якщо ти знайде У нас є
спеціальний таку ну будиночок маленький
для діточок значить щось не так значить
сигнал тривоги значить щось в неї Так
звісно що може бути психічний стан
наприклад
бачу будиночок зайшла дівчинка і плаче
що ж таке береш з руку питаєш що
трапилося ззаду бабусю а що з бабусею
Жива здорова Так але вона там де
стріляють
залишилися бувають різні ситуації буває
просто ти нас завалилась втомилась від
гри навчання Можливо хтось образив
дорослим Дай Боже це взагалі гріх але
всяке буває в житті і от такі от
халабуди Вони по-перше мають
психологічний ефект друге - це
терапевтичний ефект тому що дитина там
розкривається Вона може Ну коли діти
готуватися Це дуже класно тому що робота
може мати абсолютно різне навантаження
це може бути і для того щоб розвивати
ефективність і мрієте
але це але це мода абсолютно правильно
але це може бути і сигнал того що щось
не так і що людина там плаче або
закрилися це знову-таки дуже ніхто не
штука яка може використати набути
будь-якому випадку І ще одне що все що в
кімнаті має бути абсолютно правильно
пані сказав безпечно і в зоні
доступності не може спокійно взяти
поставити перевернути поламати ну це
діти що ти з ними зробиш Вони мають це
робити Вони мають креативити і мають
бути обов'язково матеріали для творчості
навіть ті ж самі картонні коробки
що-небудь безпечне Але в той же час що
може проявити на свою ну креативність
свої якусь фішку і музика і співай танці
все що завгодно і той же самий
науково те що говорила чи на Пані Альона
що тут про те що
сіли в коло вияснили питання і не
кучкуються а наприклад там разом якщо
вони будуть грати Хто за ким чергову
поділися на команди Це дуже величезна
роль соціалізації і дуже величезна роль
колективу і тут Важливо щоб це все
бачили вихователь і якщо діти замкнені
то він спрямовує він направляє він
розвиває Якщо ж діти навпаки вже
розкрилися тому що якщо ти не перебуває
в безпечному просторі місяць 2-3 вона
однозначно буде вже мати абсолютно
зовсім інше підходить до життя і своє
бачення і я щиро підтримую Мар'ян тому
що в Ізраїлі немає такої як у нас що ти
маєш бути там найкращим найпершим
ідеальним там не строять там формують і
те чого в нас не вистачає я бачу От наші
діти ну і дорослі часто себе або
переоцінюють або недооцінюють Чому Тому
що в дитинстві саме з нуля до 8 в них не
виховали елементарний аналіз і аналітику
я само е-е
вияснення хто ж ти є І оце посвідчення
про яке говорив Мар'ян ер
подає як свій досвід як метод підсвічує
дитини це індивідуальний підхід до
кожного І це формування майбутнього
дитини Дякую дуже хотіла додати знаєш
Напевно що для того щоб дитина почувала
себе в безпеці потрібен дуже поруч
ресурсний дорослий так І отут дуже
важливо що зараз не в ресурсі в принципі
напевно всі і я хочу тут сказати і про
вихователів яким дуже важко і Про мам і
про пап і про тих хто піклується про
дітей що їм яким дуже важко дуже важливо
не боятись просити допомоги дуже важливо
розуміти що це ок Що мені не ок дуже
важливо Це пояснювати дитині Бо ну не
всюди є вежа і не всюди є сили для того
щоб дитину на табуретку поставити і не
кожен день ми можемо прийти додому і
опуститись на рівень дитини Тобто це наш
критерій ми всі туди прагнемо
можна кожен день коли я опускаюсь і кажу
діти Я так втомилась А знаєш що мені
Ваня сказати нещода
ВНО мовчаю
Я думала я заплачу тобто нарешті Через 5
років присідання біля нього Він же хоче
віддавати
про Я хотіла ще додати до слів Насті
насправді це так є ми маємо дбати в
першу чергу про себе як знаєте колись на
нас вчили що це дуже егоїстично давайте
про себе а насправді це не так бо нас не
вчила дбати про себе і от на попередній
сесії Ми з пані Інною якраз говорили про
те що ми дорослі аби бути ресурсу маємо
семічемось наповнюватись і до слова це є
нормально дитині сказати Я зараз не ок
тому що діти теж мають вчитися
бачити дорослих які не завжди все сильні
якісь не завжди Супергерої і вас знайти
мені погано Я засмучена але водночас
сказати але я знаю що з цим робити Я
собі допоможу і так далі тому що дорослі
це Якраз ті хто там є безпекою опорою
для дітей Це також важливо і потрібно і
давайте мене ціноті вже будемо підходити
до кінця я ще хотіла
зачепити власне питання оцього цієї
взаємодії вихователів і батьків тому що
без
діалогу і без спільної роботи ми не
зможемо власне реалізувати себе найкраще
що ми прагнемо для дітей Бо насправді ми
всі знаходимося по один і той же бік
побіг дитини і тут треба аби спрацювало
стратегія він-він тобто виграш виграш де
батьки можуть за допомогою зворотнього
зв'язку покращувати якісь навички дитини
вдома і де наприклад
вихователі можуть отримуючи зворотній
зв'язок від батьків також підсвічувати
ті особливості дитини які нам є важливі
і
секунди я забула питання зараз
І власне питання полягає в тому Світлана
як батьки чи опікуни можуть бути
підтримкою дітям особливо коли йдеться
про дистанційну освіту
як батьки можуть бути підтримкою дітям
дистанційна освіта це батьки всі можуть
долучитися до речі і розказати
а-а Якщо вам треба пройти якийсь
не знаю
шлях шлях
в навчанні треба щось вивчити що дітки
вчать офлайн А ви вдома на онлайн разом
з дітками сідати і робити це тільки так
я бачу цей вихід на своєму прикладі але
це знову-таки важко Да
я не знаю проведення самостійності
мабуть да Якщо ми кажемо про те що якщо
є Мама з дитиною є дитина окремо мама
окремо і це можуть бути дуже різні від
там зварити яйце до там навчитися
вчитися Да просто різні е-е по часу
проміжок буде але ми робимо це більше
батьки щось роблять показують разом
роблять потім поступово дитина починає
бути помічником у батьків щось робити
потім більше дитина робить батьків
помічниках і потім вже дитина робить
самостійно просто про навчання це тільки
спочатку разом Бо ми не маємо робити за
дитину але ми маємо її показати
так
згадала нещодавно в мене була ситуація
на кухні я одна з трьома дітьми нікого
немає чоловік Десь там у справі допомога
немає Короче я одна Я маю бути ще Ого
весела Мені треба приготувати обід бо
Малій не можна курку сину треба Ну
короче повний пакет і вони втрьох ця
починає кричати Я розумію що зараз або я
дарюсь голови об стіну або мені треба
вмикати аніматора і ти за пластиліном
фарбами оце все розкривати в мене немає
часу що я роблю Я готувала гречаний суп
і в мультиварці рис я кидаю їм на те він
вони вже доснідали я в ці штарілки
швидко змила сніданок в цій штарілці
кладу жменьку риса жменьку гречки ламаю
спагетті
швидко біжу за однією баночкою
пластиліну розділяю пластилін побачимо і
кажу
вмикаємо фантазію що ви хочете я тільки
відвертаюсь готую суп
повертаюсь у Марії вже маленький їжак
стирчать очі вона сама встала Їй три
рочки тільки виповнилося стирчать очі
їжак і вам побудував якусь вежу з гречки
каже це буде поліцейська машина але вона
коричнева тому що вона заїхала в багнюку
і я розумію що я впоралася є така стою я
хороша мама
тобто Оце така ситуація і я думаю що в
цей момент вони навчилися із
Мені здається взагалі
завдання дорослого
в житті дитини це навчити
реалізовувати простір само навчити щось
створювати саме організовуватися зараз
вони створюють вежі із гречки Через
декілька років Вони створюють щось
корисне для людства тобто наша мета
своїм прикладом навчити створювати
підтримку знаєте насправді
можемо часто почути від дітей Мені нудно
і знаєте це нормально Коли діти нудяться
корисно це корисно вони можуть самі
шукати собі якісь заняття наше завдання
не є абсолютно заповнити простір собою
для того аби розважати дитину інку або
гуртками або гуртками Інколи ми дуже
знаєте ми дорослі дуже до себе вимогли
якщо в нас є програма садка і ми маємо
її реалізувати Ми хочемо і до останнього
реалізувати інколи коли в мене не є в
ресурсі чи вдома чи в садочку дайте
дітям папір дайте їм олівці і ви
побачите скільки вони можуть створити от
мої обожнюють коробки як і ви сказали в
прикладі Гречка і макаронія або коробка
Я даю фломастери рейтинг найцікавіших
іграшок для дітей і перші місця коробка
і палка так так
все що завгодно і тут креативність тут
фантазія проявляється і я Правда ще раз
захоплююсь станом Ну просто такі от це
терпіння тому що знаєте чого не хватає
нашим батькам особливо там нинішнім
поколінням терпіння натхнення Саме
простіше тикнути мобільний телефон на
грайся чи планшет чи комп'ютер або
просто накричати це сам найпростіше і
саме зло тому що дитина замикається
так багато Теско на дорослих тому але
щиро дорослі теж от викликають повагу
тому що от так от сформувати зацікавити
і придумати щось це теж треба мати і
терпіння і ви правильно кажете бути в
ресурсі І до речі одна із Ну мабуть
ізраїльських теж фішок Мар'ян про це так
дуже коротко сказала коли людина доросла
ви людей думає перш за все про себе про
свій ресурси тому що коли трапляється
якась трагедія щось термінове то має
досить не подумати перш за все про себе
а потім про дитину щоб її врятувати тому
що якщо
ти сам не врятуєш дитину ти не врятуєш
як тому щиро кажу що це дуже-дуже велика
навички необхідні для наших батьків і
тих тебе вчити так дорогі дорослі
давайте про себе піклуйтеся про себе бо
про вас ніхто не подбає а дорогі
вихователі ми ще раз вас вітаємо з днем
дошкілля пізніше я так знаєте зайду
наперед вони дійшла мова переліком
ресурси курси Що почитати Що дізнатися
чим надихнутися для того аби ви могли
скерувати і допомогти дітям їхню енергію
знаєте в правильне русло от дуже дякуємо
всім нашим сонячним спікерам тримаємося
разом Слава Україні Слава
[музика]
Дорогі колеги А зараз ми розпочнемо
церемонію нагородження працівників
дошкільної освіти Міністерства освіти і
науки України
[музика]
з метою відзначення працівників сфери
освіти за бездоганну працю плідно
педагогічну діяльність високі досягнення
у навчанні та вихованні молоді високі
професіоналізм сумлінне виконання
службових обов'язків та вагомий
особистий внесок у розвиток сфери освіти
і науки України нагородити нагрудний
знак Міністерства освіти і науки Василь
Сухомлинський скотенко Людмила
Вікторівна директорка дошкільного
навчального закладу номер 786 міста
Києва на грудним знаком Міністерства
освіти і науки України Василь
Сухомлинський дарага Віра Іванівна
директор закладу дошкільної освіти
комбінованого типу спадкоємець боярської
селищної ради Київської області над
грудним знаком Міністерства освіти і
науки відмінник освіти Кульчицька Ірина
Анатоліївна вихователь закладу
дошкільної освіти
№18 зірочка камінець-подільського
міської ради Хмельницької області
грудним знаком Міністерства освіти і
науки відміннику освіти Олексюк Василина
Миколаївна директор закладу дошкільної
освіти №3 барвінок берегометської
селищної ради Вижницького району
Чернівецької області почесною грамотою
Міністерства освіти і науки через Шнюк
Олена Анатоліївна завідувач дошкільного
навчального закладу № 30 Вінницької
міської ради почесною грамотою
Міністерства освіти і науки кондюх Леся
Володимирівна директор закладу
дошкільної освіти №3
пустомитівської міської ради Львівської
області
почесною грамотою Міністерство освіти і
науки майстренку Олена Володимирівна
директор закладу дошкільної освіти
сонечко комбінованого типу менського
міської ради Чернігівської області
грамотою Міністерство освіти і науки
Шевчук Олена Михайлівна
вихователь-методист закладу дошкільної
освіти веселка лука мелешківської
міської ради Вінницької області
Новосад Олена Василівна вихователь
методист закладу дошкільної освіти
компенсуючого типу №40 Рівненської
області
панчішна Лариса Іванівна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти номер один
краснокутської селищної ради
богодухівського району Харківської
області то білку Оксана Михайлівна
вихователь методист закладу дошкільної
освіти Струмочок золотоніської міської
ради
Герасименко Людмила Віталіївна завідувач
дошкільного навчального закладу номер
три ічнянської міської ради
Чернігівської області
Свистун Наталія Євгенівна консультант з
дошкільної освіти комунальної установи
Бершадський центр професійного розвитку
педагогічних працівників Вінницької
області Дуда Валентина Василівна
вихователь-методист грутківського
закладу дошкільної освіти сонечко
камінь-каширської міської ради во
Сумської області Приступа Лілія
Євгенівна музичне керівник дошкільного
навчального закладу № 7 Нововолинської
міської ради Волинської області
Костецька Вікторія Миколаївна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти компенсуючого
типу номер 82 криворізької міської ради
Дніпропетровської області
Чайка Анжела Михайлівна вихователька
закладу дошкільної освіти номер 244
Дніпровської міської ради як углева
Олена Миколаївна директор закладу
дошкільної освіти комбінованого типу
номер 6 криворізької міської ради
Дніпропетровської області
димитрюк Анна Георгіївна завідувач
закладу дошкільної освіти №10 Калинка
Покровської міської ради Донецької
області як у Ново Вікторія Вікторівна
вихователь-методист закладу дошкільної
освіти №9 ромашка мирноградської міської
ради Донецької щастя чамур Ірина
Михайлівна керівник дошкільного
навчального закладу компенсуючого типу
номер 25 дзвіночок Донецької області
Ковальська Олена Петрівна учитель
дефектолог закладу дошкільної освіти
комбінованого типу номер 15 ромашка
Бердичівської міської ради Житомирської
області
Криворучко Алла Леонідівна директор
центру розвитку дитини Берізка
романівської селищної ради Житомирської
області у стьожанінова Андріана
Степанівна музична музичне керівник
дошкільного навчального закладу номер
два сонечко хустської міської ради
Закарпатської області
феденишинець Христина Іванівна
практичний психолог закладу дошкільної
освіти №1 кольчинської селищної ради
Мукачівського району Закарпатської
області
крайнова Олена Вікторівна директор
спеціального закладу дошкільної освіти
номер 14 вербичка запорізької міської
ради
Данилюк Марія Миколаївна директор
комарівського закладу дошкільної освіти
сонечко Галицької міської ради
івано-франківської області
семотюк Ярослава Богданівна директор
джурівського закладу дошкільної освіти
Теремок снятинської міської ради
Коломийського району івано-франківської
області
дралюк Яна Миколаївна директор
дошкільного навчального закладу № 100
казка Дарницького району міста Києва
кобенко Наталія Олександрівна учитель
логопед дошкільного навчального закладу
номер 720 Печерського району міста Києва
Левко Наталії Григорівна вихователь
дошкільного підрозділу журавлик
великодимерського ліцею великодимерської
селищної ради Броварського району
Київської області не Войт Лілія
Григорівна інструктор з фізкультури
закладу дошкільної освіти дзвіночок
дмитрівської сільської ради
сорочинського району Київської області
рудевич Олександра Михайлівна учитель
логопед закладу дошкільної освіти
комбінованого типу Золота рибка
Долинського міської ради Кіровоградської
області Косенко Наталія Миколаївна
вихователь-методист лисичанського
дошкільного навчального закладу №8
світлячок Луганської області
лисицька Наталія Олексіївна
вихователь-методист лисичанського
дошкільного навчального закладу номер 7
іскрка Луганської області
саприкіна Оксана Валеріївна вихователь
методист лисичанського дошкільного
навчального закладу №3 міхно Галина
Євстахівна директор закладу дошкільної
освіти сонечко комбінованого типу
моршинської міської ради Львівської
області Пришляк Наталія Михайлівна
директор закладу дошкільної освіти
журавлик Миколаївської міської ради
Стрийського району Львівської області
Атаманчук Віктор Васильович вихователь
закладу дошкільної освіти дзвіночок при
вільненську сільської ради баштанського
району Миколаївської області
колеснік Тетяна Анатоліївна завідувач
дошкільного навчального закладу №2 міста
Миколаєва Львова Ірина Вікторівна
головний спеціаліст з питань охорони
дитинства та дошкільної освіти
управління освіти Вознесенської міської
ради Миколаївської області
Бурковська Тетяна Василівна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти Золотий ключик
саф'янівської сільської ради
Ізмаїльського району Одеської області
георгію Людмила савелівна завідувач
закладу дошкільної освіти комбінованого
типу ясел-садка номер 34
дельфінятко ізмаїльської міської ради
Одеської області
магалюк Інна Василівна директор закладу
дошкільної освіти №1 Малятко
комбінованого типу міста
білгород-дністровський Одеської області
Бойко Тетяна Володимирівна вихователь
гаркушинської гімназії миргородської
міської ради Полтавської області
Радченко Наталія Миколаївна Музичний
керівник заклад з дошкільної освіти
веселка гребінської міської ради
Полтавської області морочинець Тетяна
Василівна директор закладу дошкільної
освіти комбінованого типу номер 10
вараською міської ради Рівненської
області
ніколаюк Світлана Миколаївна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти №3
комбінованого типу Дубенської міської
ради Рівненської області
Соломко Вікторія Олександрівна Музичний
керівник дошкільного навчального закладу
номер 14 Золотий півник Сумської міської
ради
Климюк Тетяна Мар'янівна вихователь
методи закладу дошкільної освіти №2
Тернопільської міської ради обшарська
Раїса Володимирівна директор дошкільного
навчального закладу номер один міста
Чортків Тернопільської області
шляхтичук Валентина Михайлівна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти бджілка село
Дунаїв Кременецької міської ради
Тернопільської області
порціян Інна Михайлівна директор закладу
дошкільної освіти ромашка зачепилівської
селищної ради красноградського району
Харківської області кліпановська Наталія
Миколаївна директор закладу дошкільної
освіти №2
летичівської селищної ради Хмельницького
району горобець Надія Степанівна
директор закладу дошкільної освіти номер
два Берізка деражнянської міської ради
Хмельницької області
габліані Марина Валентинівна
вихователь-методист закладу дошкільної
освіти комбінованого типу номер 8
дзвіночок канівської міської ради
Черкаської області
Косенко Наталія Володимирівна завідувач
дошкільного навчального закладу номер 11
зірочка комбінованого типу смілянської
міської ради Черкаської області
Лебідь Ніна Федорівна вихователь
дошкільного навчального закладу центру
розвитку дитини №35 Попелюшка кам'янське
міської ради Черкаської області роман
Надія Миколаївна директор горбівського
закладу дошкільної освіти Пролісок
острицької сільської ради і
герцаївського району Чернівецької
області
фарбатюк Марина Георгіївна директор
закладу дошкільної освіти юрковецької
сільської ради Чернівецького району
Чернівецької області Боженко Жанна
Аркадіївна учитель логопед ясел садка
номер чотири городнянської міської ради
Чернігівської області
[музика]
Дорогі колеги Дякуємо що були з нами зі
святом вас до зустрічі
[музика]